you don't really think about style you
just you're always trying to find
that kind of appropriate language is a
good
way of putting it and i think that that
just kind of emerges as a style it's not
a kind of premeditated thing
the past is more interesting just in
terms of telling a story
uh who needs you know you walk out the
door and you're in contemporary new york
so who needs us for that well so you
know it's there's an exoticism to it
even if you're you're not even if it's
not uh romanticized or sentimental as
it's you know it's a once upon a time
thing it's immediately transporting
you're going somewhere
as the world is a horrible
unforgiving and capricious place and it
doesn't you know conform to one's
expectations or
certainly you know genre conventions why
do your movies look so good because we
work with good dps it's also why is the
music so interesting in our movies
because we work with really good
musicians and composers i'm sure it's
the same with you writing you go like
yeah what's uh what would be good next
and maybe part of it is because you've
internalized some structural thing but
it's not like
it's not like some target you're aiming
for
[Music]
was there any template like i would
think with a first featured script
there's some
helps to have some kind of guideline
like what happens in each of the 3x i
don't
i don't know how to do three-act
structure we don't either i don't know
what that is i mean i've heard of the
three hats
yeah yeah no we just proceeded have
proceeded by
feel sort of
you know beginning where does it go
seems like it's about time to wind it up
actually it's the same with your writing
you go like yeah what's
what would be good next and maybe part
of it is because you've internalized
some structural thing but it's not like
it's not like some target you're aiming
for violence in this movie or violence
generally for you guys is this something
that you think i mean is it in every
movie well it's a very violent i mean
one of the things we said to scott rudin
one of the first things we
sort of discussed with him when he sent
us the book
was you know
it's a very there's a lot of violence in
the book and it's
very important
as there is in a lot of cormac's novels
and and
and it's very important to
the story
and we couldn't conceive of sort of
soft-peddling that in the movie and and
um really doing anything resembling the
book you know would have been
nonsensical and we wanted to make sure
that
that that scott was on the
same page with that of course he was i
mean he wanted he wanted to make the
book he didn't want to make some sort of
studio hollywood version of of you know
no country for all men um
but
it's
you know it's about a character
confronting a very
arbitrary violent brutal world and you
have to see that you see it in the story
as it's written and you have to see it
in the in the movie in order to
understand what
um in order to understand anything i
think about what
the the
the characters are
what they're about and what they're
confronting and what they're trying to
make sense of
oh it's shocking in the book as well
that the
josh's character who seems to be kind of
the main guy gets killed off stage as it
were in the book and not even by the bad
guy whom he doesn't even get to meet but
by some nameless schmoes um
but i you know i
why is that or why did that appeal to us
it's like kind of it's
yeah although it's kind of shocking and
unconventional especially in a movie
maybe even more so than novel it seems
you know it's connected to what the
story is about which is
uh you know
the world is a horrible unforgiving and
capricious place and it doesn't you know
conform to
one's expectations or
certainly you know genre conventions and
that's you know
and you get to experience what violence
truly is which is a sudden
you know
subtraction of somebody and i haven't
seen that in film i think that's
extremely unique and risky i heard of a
guy who actually thought i mean he said
he thought that three quarters of the
movie was a masterpiece and the last
quarter after it finished he went
outside and he started kicking things
it is interesting from a storytelling
point of view too and it was to us in
the i mean
what ethan was saying about this sort of
it being it's sort of conforming to the
sort of ideas in the book and the sort
of capricious nature of the of the
of the of the world and
um and how the story sort of reflects
that and that shift reflects that is
sort of what was interesting to us but
in addition to that it's an interesting
it was interesting to us in reading the
book that
you do follow the movie through or you
follow the novel through because it's
much the same the novel in the movie
um with following this one character and
sort of investing in this character and
you believe the movie is about this
character and
and the outcome is going to
take a
trajectory that you're more or less
familiar with and cormac
you know he he he he he changes that
three quarters the way through and what
he does is he makes you then sort of
think well if it's not what i
thought it was about what is it about
um
and i think that's what
the last
third of the story in the novel sort of
tells you and that's what we were trying
to do in the movie as well i mean the
question you guys must get all the time
i have to ask you this
um so many of your movies are set in the
past
um more than half of them as a matter of
fact what is it but they're all very
anti-nostalgic looks at the past
yeah yeah yes to both i agree yes why is
that i don't know uh the past is more
interesting i don't know
just in terms of telling a story
uh who needs you know you walk out the
door and you're in contemporary new york
so who needs us for that
so so you know it's there's an exoticism
to it even if you're you're not even if
it's not uh
romanticized or sentimental as it's you
know it's a once upon a time thing
um
that's interesting and
also just where as a setting you know
the setting has some i don't know you
know how to describe it some emotional
charge like you look at a cover of
freewheeling and it says something to
you you know and that you know you can
use that you can harness that
whatever power that has which is really
hard to verbalize but it has some kind
of power
one of the things you get to do when you
do a period movie is
create
a world
for the camera
you have to create it in
sort of
globally and in every sort of little
detail which is actually a lot of fun i
mean one of the fun things that
we did in relation in connection with
this movie is there are album covers you
see in the movie and doing
research about those and looking at a
lot of them and trying to imagine
taking internalizing those sort of
design ideas and that and just the
spirit of those things and making them
yourself it's fun
i mean it's part of the pleasure of
making movies is doing that sort of
thing and when it's a period movie it's
a different kind of pleasure than
[Music]
specific to that than if you're doing a
contemporary film
and it's just somehow
i don't know his different way of saying
the same thing it's immediately
transporting you're going somewhere this
movie was not based
on
an actual crime who says was it yeah
yeah it was yeah and this story is
completely based on a real event yeah
the story is the characters
you know we we weren't interested in
making a documentary and the characters
are really inventions um
based on
the sort of outline of events
so we invented the characters
um
um and they're really sort of our
creation in the creation of the actors
who played the parts has your style
changed over time do you think you know
it's such a funny question about style a
vexed question because
you don't really think about style you
just
certainly i'm not saying does something
doesn't emerge that you can identify as
that but you don't think about it that
way when you're making something so much
you just kind of think about what's
appropriate to
the scene or the piece as a whole or
you're always trying to find
that kind of appropriate language is a
good
way of putting it and someone said that
earlier
and i think that that just kind of
emerges as a style it's not a kind of
premeditated thing
i think if it is premeditated it might
get a little
um
i don't know it might get a little
self-con it would be self-conscious you
know um
so if there's a style in looking back i
don't know it's hard it's harder for me
to identify consistencies in style in
terms of what i've done in the past
from blood simple to this you know i i
look more at it i like it more in terms
of you're on a kind of
discovery for the right language for
each of the things that you're doing
it's things of taste that emerge you
know
and the taste may be personal and as
you're looking for those things that
you keep reflecting your own taste and
that becomes
an element of the style i guess what you
would call it but
but you but i think and the ambition is
to say i don't have a style i'm just
trying to do what's right for the
material right i think that's the
ambition that's the way you want to feel
about it with your actors
josh and scarlet have worked with you
guys as well before are there actors
that maybe you'll meet them in your or
you know of them and you'll say you know
what these they would be great for not
this project but the next one you kind
of have people in mind for subsequent
projects as things going on sometimes we
tend to write a lot for a specific
actors it's true or
um
the other way it works frequently is
that we'll work with someone on a
specific
movie in a specific part and have a lot
of fun with them and uh
and then just start thinking about what
else
might be fun to see them play so
that can be the sort of beginning of a
new project or we're working on another
project and
and
and we end up writing for that actor
again but tell me more about your
philosophy of making movies that
reflected in what we just talked about
well it is kind of what josh says we
have a plan
because we're chicken you know we don't
want to have to go in
you don't trust your actor what
but just in terms of being
our own ability to extemporize on this
set or you know
the obligation of extemporizing on this
set we don't want that we want to have a
plan for how we're going to shoot the
scene whatever it is so we walk in with
a plan which as josh josh says is always
kind of subject to
change
but uh you know it's kind of a it's a
security plan you know the mythology
about alfred hitchcock
in fact he was the biggest promoter of
it
was that idea that you know once once i
actually get on the set the only thing
that can happen is that something can go
wrong he's already made the movie in his
head and
and uh he was
he also was
sort of you know
very very prepared
to the extent of having pre-thought the
movie before he started production we're
not you know
i'm not even sure that's true of alfred
hitchcock in reality i i don't think he
could have made 50 movies without
enjoying the process of being on the set
and working with people it's such an
extremely
social and collaborative process and and
it was true that we prepare
maybe to an extent greater than a lot of
other directors who
you know that's just part of our process
it's also true that we're we like the
process on the set of actually
seeing what happens being open to what
happens when you go on to a into a new
space when you're working with new
people be the actors or technical people
um and we do have storyboards but
actually we don't look at them very much
while we're shooting and once they've
been done
we probably we almost never look at the
storyboards we have them in the back of
our minds and we follow them to a
certain extent
but um
but but
that changes a lot as we go through the
production from a writing point of view
guys um
obviously all of your films have got
some humor in them but something that
that like this sort of along the lines
of intolerable cruelty or big lebowski
is there a different process that you
have to writing
comedies outright comedies like this
rather than things like no country for
old man or inside lou and davis
not really i
i uh
no you just
sit down and try and make the story go
and sometimes they're
they're
comedies and sometimes they're not i uh
but no the process is really the same
i'd be hard-pressed to tell you what the
process was on either of them frankly
but i i it's just problem solving really
well that monologue alone i think sent
european film theorists and everything
to start seeing it as an anti-american
commentary about the state of sort of
late cold war i mean did it entertain
you when you started hearing some of
these theories about it it happened a
lot unlike barton fink
yeah a lot of our movies people want
like
i don't know why like people want social
commentary and stuff but the story isn't
enough for some people maybe it's
because we just
because it's the only thing we know we
just write story american stories and
some of them are regional stories and we
never kind of have gone outside of that
and so people think that there's some
kind of larger
comment political commentary about
this country in it or that that's part
of the design of the movie
when it wasn't any part of the design of
the movie
you